Let us look at adaptation
a little bit more deeply.
So once again here is the process
of case-based reasoning.
I have kind of blurred
the retrieval step.
We're going to assume here that
the retrieval of the case has already
occurred, perhaps using the KNN
method that we discussed last time.
Last time we also said two other things.
One, that a fundamental conundrum that
AR agent faces that the problems they
encounter are usually very complex
from a computational perspective.
And they have only limited
calculative resources.
So then how can they address
computationally complex problems,
with limited calculative resources,
in near real-time?
Seemingly effortlessly.
And we said part of the answer might
be that memory supplies with an answer.
But we are going to make
a small amendment to it.
Memory supplies with an answer,
an almost correct answe,r so
that the adaptation that we have
to do is very small, very minor.
It's a tweak.
As an example of adaptation
being mostly tweaking,
consider this simple problem,
the everyday problem of cooking meals.
So you may have a recipe for
your favorite kind of meal.
And imagine at this time you're going
to have your favorite meal, perhaps
with different company, or perhaps with
a different kind of salad or appetizer.
Well in that case you might tweak
your recipe for that particular dish.
You're not going to change
it in a radical way,
you're simply making
a small change to it.
>> So, Ashoke, another example of this
that comes to mind very readily for me,
goes back to your programming
example from earlier in this lesson.
One thing that almost every
program I write has to
do is input data from a file.
But right now, I couldn't write
that process from scratch.
What I always do is I look at however
I did it the previous time, and
I'll modify it for the new folder or
the new kind of data or
the new kind of file I'm reading from.
But really I'm just taking the same
process and tweaking it for
my new problem.
>> That's a good point, David.
In fact in the design commonly
there's an old cliche,
which says that all designers redesign.
Design is fundamentally evolutionary,
we take all designs and
we evolve them slightly and
that's how we get a new design.
And the same thing is happening
in case-based reasoning here.
It is saying that often this
particular solutions that we
come up with are revolutionary in
the nature in the sense that they
are small tweaks over
previous solutions.
So the next question becomes,
how can we adapt an old case to meet
the requirements of new problem?
There are potentially
several ways of doing it.
We will discuss three important ways,
perhaps the three most common
ways of adapting a case.
They are called the model-based method,
the recursive case-based method,
and the rule-based method.